I'm going to start a $10 million trash
collecting business so if you want to
start a business this video is for you
we're going to turn this trash Into Cash
the first thing you need to do is get
customers and the easiest way to do that
is to talk to people you already know
and the easiest way to do that is to
pull up your phone look in your contacts
and find one let's call
Caleb yo hey what's up man are you at
that wedding I am yeah well quick
question for you this may seem out of
the blue is anyone taking out your trash
oh [__] no it's probably just sitting
there smelling awful do you know anybody
else who might be at the wedding who's
also not taking out their trash probably
but what are you talking about like I
know this is out of blue I'll explain
why so right now I'm starting my little
Trash cleaning business I want to help
five or 10 people and just do my service
for free I'll do everything and if it is
good if you're open to leave me a review
it mean the world to me and if it sucks
I hope you tell me so I can make it
better dude that would be perfect and
I'm a ger F I [__] hate touching
well I'll tell you what why don't I do
it for free you're you're helping me out
if it's good and you like the service I
can talk to you about you know what it
would look like afterwards in like two
weeks that work that sounds incredible
yeah thank you and uh the other folks
that you know do you think you do a
three-way text intro with me yeah
absolutely thanks for supporting me man
I really appreciate it so that is number
one of four different ways that one
person can let other people know about
their stuff there are eight ways in
total but today we're only going to talk
about four of them and they are called
unsurprisingly the core 4 welcome to
Money Center where we break down this
week's money-making activities here
we've got a strapping men in what
appears to be a tuxedo tank top we're
going to watch this game footage are you
at that wedding interesting first
question I'm guessing this is a
personalized tidbit that he found out
from the social medias doing a little
pre-research or pre-search this may seem
out of the blue is anyone taking out
your trash woo and right for the right
for the jugular all right let's see what
was just happening all right so we
acknowledged what they said they were
going to the wedding the compliment was
that oh that's nice now could he have
gone for a better compliment for sure
I'd give that a four out of 10 on the
compliment scale now what he didn't do
was tie to a positive character trait
that would have been bonus points now
what does he do next he asks another
question and leads the conversation
whatever Direction he wants to go in
this instance talking about trash
anytime someone is doing something that
you want to do for them they spend the
same resource which is time and so all
you have to do whether you're traving
Fitness Services cleaning services trash
taking out Services IT services whatever
it is you say hey how's all this stuff
going they say great and you say how do
you have time to insert the thing that
you're trying to sell and everyone's
like man I wish I had more time and you
said oh boy I just happen to be a time
salesman and I can give you some back
all right let's go back into this game
footage it looks like he's following a
script which makes it less impressive or
does it he's actually following a script
because if you don't know what you're
doing just stick with the script rpt I
think that's what he's actually reading
do you think he can read do you know
anybody else who might be at the wedding
who's awesome he already assumed the
clothes on this one and he's going for
more do you know anybody who is looking
to dream outcome not have the trash
during the wedding as a quick tidbit
this is an outline it's not going to be
perfect and honestly when you do 20 or
30 or 50 of these you'll start to find
your own Rhythm these are the big things
if we're thinking about these as
Milestones it's like hey I'm not asking
them I'm asking if they know anybody now
in this particular instance the guy was
like man I he clearly exhibited the
issue but if you've been like no I
actually do have somebody who's taking
care of the trash or whatever couple
directions you could go there it' be
like awesome are they doing it for free
and then they would say no and be like
well I will and then boom you could get
the business or you just say hey do you
know anybody who is it's a very easy
transition so you're not asking them for
business you're not soliciting you're
asking if they knowbody and so then you
give them the reason why because I'm
taking on five case studies now case
studies is a word that I didn't use in
this but if you said hey I'm taking on
five trials or five people for free and
I'm just trying get some testimonials
some reviews okay let's go back to the
uh the game footage and if it sucks I
hope you tell me so I can make it better
and we just outlined both outcome
scenarios in the explanation which is
either I'm good and you leave me a
review which is my ask or I suck and you
just tell me so either you get feedback
or you get a review and it works great
and the nice thing is you can make money
three different ways from somebody for
free cuz everybody in the stands is like
he going to make money give them away
stuff for free your time is valuable
your time isn't valuable because if it
were valuable you'd be making money and
if you're not making money right now
guess what value says zero this gives
you practice and feedback from
friendlies which is a great way to start
category one is that they will get the
free service and be like this was
awesome keep doing it and I'll pay you
they literally just become customers
option two is they then say hey I don't
want to do this but I'll leave you a
review so then you get a review version
three of them making you money is that
they just send you a friend even if it's
not them and they could do all of those
things somebody could leave your a
review send you a friend and become a
customer but they could do any of those
things individually and if you want
Secret Door Number Four they could also
say you know what you weren't good I
don't want to send you a friend and I
don't want to be a customer but I'll
tell you what you could do better and
that also makes you money in the long
term why don't I do it for free you're
you're helping me out and see notice the
frame you're helping me out letting me
do this for free it's not hey you owe me
one because I'm doing this for free for
you wrong frame of mind if you come in
at that you're going to be a weirdo and
everyone's going to sense it cuz you're
going to have this weird resentment WS
people because you're like I can't
believe I'm giving the stuff away for
free they should be thanking me no they
shouldn't cuz you have no reputation and
you have no track record cuz if you did
you wouldn't have to give it away for
free but you are because you haven't
done it yet and that's okay I'll and
notice he's still reading from this this
screen so he might not even have a brain
brains are optional in this that's how
simple this is when you ask people who
know you the other folks that you know
do you think you do a three-way text
intro with me ooh snuck it back in so
remember earlier he said hey do you know
anybody he said yeah I do know some
people he remembered and said hey why
don't we do a three-way not the way
you're thinking I see you but how do we
do a three-way intro and the reason you
do that is because if you say hey can
you make the intro to me they have to
remember but if you say right now hey do
a three-way text while I'm here there's
two things happen one is that you get
the lead and here's the second sneaky
thing that happens is that because you
actually have an intro of a third party
in the message group the person who's
getting intro is way less rude overall I
think I think 4 and A2 out of 10 maybe a
4.6 and I'm mostly giving that because
of the hair and the tuxedo tank
regardless this goes to show you that
you don't need to have a brain you can
follow half of a script and you can
still get a customer by talking to
people who you know and asking them if
they know anybody and just like that you
can start your trash cleaning business
because there are four ways you can make
money from free people they become
customers they leave you a review who
get you a customer they send you a
friend or they give you feedback that
could make you better so that you can
eventually actually be worth what you
want to charge but there are two
limitations Let's Walk This Way first
limitation is that you only have so much
time you're going to be calling people
you're going to reach out to people and
trying to get them to try your services
or your products of some sort you can
only do that so many hours of the day
cuz it's just you limitation number two
is that you only know so many people you
add up your email list your contacts in
your phone your followers on social
media across every platform that you're
on if you're on platforms you might have
a thousand people who know you well if
you did a 100 of those a day in 10 days
you would have reached out to everybody
now that doesn't mean that you shouldn't
reach out to them again you should but
at that point you start to run into some
friction so we just got our first
customers from warm Outreach as in
talking to people we know oneon-one now
we're going to transition to getting our
first customers from posting free
content let there be light is it on cool
want to know the best way to get your
husband to take the trash out two things
number one instead of saying hey honey
will you take the trash out you say hey
would you mind taking the trash out hey
would you be opposed to taking the trash
out would it be a huge inconvenience for
you to take the trash out if you say it
like that instead of of a yes based
question it's a no based question cuz
they're like no it wouldn't be a huge
inconvenience I wouldn't mind at all and
then they take it for you because people
are more likely to say no to things then
yes but you get them to say yes by
saying no the other way to make sure
they keep doing it is that after your
husband or your spouse does it that you
reward them for doing it and that's
where you say thanks so much that meant
so much to me it's like you're my hero
any of those types of things make it
more likely that someone's going to do
it again now if you don't want to use
any of these persuasion tactics just
call 1800 Alex TR and I'll do it for you
and you can say you got it for your
husband as a gift because he means so
much to you trash is gross to everyone
but me but if you're one of those people
there's three ways that you can actually
not have to touch your trash way number
one use a bag you take the bag just like
a pooper scooper you take your hand and
then you can go over the whole thing and
then you dump it way number two is you
use tools like
these go down touch your trash and there
you go hands free and way number three
is you can call 1800 Alex trash because
I love the smell of trash and I will do
it for you and you are helping somebody
who actually has barely any way to smell
and so I wear these because I can't
smell that good and so this is a natural
line of work for me because I get to do
something that doesn't bother me at all
and bothers other people here's how
making free content Works do you make
free valuable stuff for your audience so
much so that they say give us more give
us more could either be more free value
or paying you money for the services
that you offer now let's actually break
this down in Real Time with these videos
want to know the best way to get your
husband to take the trash out what was
that that was part one of content which
is hook now notice how many seconds is
that 3 seconds in the first 3 seconds
are the most important 3 seconds in the
content video two things number one so
notice I have a two-step framework that
I then introduce in the beginning give
step one give what it is then give an
explanation of why it works and then I
move on to step two and repeat the cycle
and so that that is a retaining cycle
which you can either use lists steps or
stories or combinations of all three to
keep the audience engaged and right now
I'm going through list steps and stories
making this now let's keep watching this
one and see where this guy takes it just
call 1800 Alex trash and I'll do it for
you and you can say you got it for your
husband as a gift because he means so
much to you and so the idea with the
reward is that you want someone to share
the last piece so it's either something
that subverts the audience meaning
something that they laugh at or think is
funny or it's some sort of action that
you're going to have them take now
ideally here this is funny enough that
someone would send it to their friends
now let's look at number two and break
this one down together trash is gross to
everyone but me so trash is gross to
everyone but me is a weird but probably
effective hook because curiosity people
like why is this person talking about
this and the thing with content is
you're going to make many many many
things and sometimes you would be
surprised by what works and what doesn't
so often times you can start with a
crazy topic or you can start with a
crazy question or or just a fact or a
statement that people might find jarring
any of those things might catch
someone's attention so that they keep
watching way number one use a bag and so
each of these is an open loop so I'm
opening the loop and then I close it
with what the thing is but you're still
like well what's number two and what's
number three and the idea is that you
retain them so that they watch it and
way number three is you can call 1800
Alex trash because I love the smell of
trash there you go fun little wrap up on
the video we've got a hook we've got
some retention tactic which has a a step
for a story and then some sort of reward
or call to action at the end and just
like that we have made two pieces of
content following the hook retain reward
framework that you can use for any type
of business now Pro tip on this if I
were to start a local trash business I
would say there's one of two directions
I would take my content in general you
could also inter splice them one is
actually talking to Consumers and saying
here here's some tips about trash you
probably didn't know about things that
can make their life better independent
of using my services or you could make
content targeted at people who you would
want to work work at your trash company
so it might be targeted more around what
a Salesman job or a trash collecting job
might look like so that you can attract
more Talent either of those strategies
work and you could probably do both
together cuz you would eventually just
be known as the trash kick all right I'm
going to give you a couple quick tips
that have worked well for me on making
content number one people need to be
reminded more than need to be taught so
a lot of times we have this idea that
I've said this thing one time in content
therefore I should never say it again
because I would be repeating myself but
it's arrogant to assume that 100% of
your audience 100% of the time consumes
100% of your content and also that if
they consume something one time they
wouldn't want to consume it again Andor
a version that's just slightly different
from the original you'll probably see
tweet reels from me that also appear in
video format for me that also make their
way into captions and full posts on the
exact same concept and then I also talk
about them in podcast think about
yourself who do you follow you probably
know the themes of stuff that they're
talking about on on a regular basis and
you follow them because you want to be
reminded I've watched comedians do the
same bit over and over again because I
think it's hilarious and so it works the
same way with your own content if people
like something make more of it another
one is that in the content that I just
showed you I made a call to action at
the end you could obviously not make a
call to action at the end at all you
could just make the content and cut it
and then that would be perfectly fine
and you could just expect that people
would make comments they would like it
or sometimes DM you anyways just cuz
they want to find out more I think that
that one actually would work because I
made the third weight kind of funny and
the cool thing is is that anybody who
likes or engages or comments on your
posts are leads because you can then
message them a lead is a person you can
contact and an engage lead is someone
who shown interest in the stuff that you
have we create content so that we can
get people to engage so that we can then
say hey I saw that you engaged with my
thing that gives you a reason to reach
out to them without seeming like a
scumbag and so like that is how you can
generate leads for free using content
I'm going to give you a frame shift that
helped me a lot in the beginning when
you're making
content looking at the number of views
can be depressing because then you think
man I suck no one likes me but I started
to imagine whatever the number of views
was as the size of a room I was talking
in and so if I was willing to do a lunch
and learn for my trash business with 15
people in it I was stoked and so the
idea that 17 people watch my video is a
full room it's a classroom and so the
idea that I could do that and reach them
for free just reframing it and not
comparing it to what a million clip view
is but just saying what does 17 people
look like wow that was worth it and if
you can keep that perspective it becomes
way less discouraging and everyone
starts at this one big magical
number it's not bad it's not you suck
it's not that you're late everyone
starts here and you build from there and
so that is how we got our customers from
our second different way to advertise
posting free content now we'll
transition to reaching out to strangers
oneon-one to get our next
[Music]
customers hello hey how's it going
pretty good reason I'm knocking on your
door is because I helped the Johnson's
your neighbor take out their trash and
they sent me over here to ask you if you
have somebody who takes care of your
trash for you I do not well would you be
opposed to me doing it for for you no no
actually that sounds incredible all
right well fantastic so if you have any
trash right now I can just grab it yeah
I'd be good with it yeah all right
fantastic cuz I can take that out to my
truck and then I'll get the rest of your
stuff I do not want to touch it honestly
so like that would be very helpful thank
you hello hey how's it going good reason
I'm here because I took out the
Johnson's trash it's what I do for a
living and I was curious if you have
somebody who taks out your trash I do
yeah yeah well are they as awesome and
smiley as
me I guess not do they also do it for
free for this month no because I'll do
both of those the extra Smiley stuff is
on me if it's actually free yeah yeah
it's free for the first month and after
that it goes at 29 bucks a month okay
yeah yeah let's do it okay fantastic
well if you got a bag I'll grab what I
have and then I'll bring them out to the
truck and I'll come back with my
cleaning supplies yeah let's do it all
right
hey how's it going hello
hello I take out the Johnson's trash and
they wanted me to take out your trash so
guess what just happened I got to know
and guess how much poorer I am 0% poor
and so you know what yeses can change
your life but you can have as as many
NOS as you want and nothing else changes
and so all we do is we roll the dice
again d D dum dum dum dum and we're back
for the cold Outreach breakdown it is
you reaching out one1 to strangers and
you can do that via email phone call
direct message SMS voicemail or knocking
on someone's door like I demonstrated
now let's break down these puppies one
by one this was the nice guy reason I'm
knocking on your door so right before we
get into this there's a lot of setup
here so number one I have trash over my
shoulder the reason for that is because
I'm already visually demonstrating what
I do and it's especially I'm dressed in
work clothes you might think is this
person here to fix something I have
curiosity working on my side cuz he
might have a peephole or look through
the window before answering the door
which most people do so before even
getting the knock in the door I'm trying
to look a certain way so that it
increases the likelihood that they open
the door now the second thing is that
I've got a huge secret weapon that most
people don't do so the reason I talked
earlier about giving away free stuff is
that once you do give one person free
stuff what do you think you should do
with that free person you should
leverage it to the greatest degree
possible to make as much money as you
possibly can for giving away something
for free because if I can get 10 more
sales from the one person I gave for
free by name dropping them or by using
them as an intro or a segue into a sales
pitch that's worth giving away the
service for one person and so in this
example the Johnson which is the
neighbor I could give one person in an
entire neighborhood free service and
then go to every other door and say hey
I work with the Johnson's which then
creates trust and they're like okay this
is legit and then I can bridge in so
right now do that in the first couple
seconds cuz I want to disarm them so
they don't act rudely to me if someone
knows that you know someone they know
they will act much more polite to you
and be far more likely to give you more
time to make whatever presentation you
want to make and they sent me over here
to ask you if you have somebody who
takes care of your trash notice the
question that I'm asking after
proceeding it with I help the Johnson's
out I ask the individual does he have
somebody who's doing this particular
service cuz I'm not saying hey do you
want me to take your trash out for you
I'm asking if they have someone who's
doing it because then I'm leading them
on a path that I have an answer on both
sides it's a yes no question that I have
100% response that's good on either
scenario I do not so this one is an easy
one cuz they're like I don't have
anybody who does this particular service
and believe it or not as crazy as it
sounds it's actually even better
sometimes that they do have someone
because that means they already are
willing to pay for the service so by the
way if someone already has or pays for
something they're more likely to buy
from you not less would you be a opposed
to me doing it for you and so that's a
no-based question so rather than saying
hey do you want me to do it I'm saying
would you be opposed to or to be a great
inconvenience to you Etc where it's an
easier yes by saying no than a pure yes-
based question for all the yes based
salesmen myself included I've closed
plenty of sales I'm just saying you
ready to start open to go on Monday
let's get started whatever it doesn't
mean it doesn't work it just means that
in general when you ask a huge
population a slightly higher percentage
will say yes to a no question no no
actually that sounds incredible great we
got the yes and we move on now as a side
note here once you get the yes shut the
[__] up and go everything you say after
the point they said yes is increasing
the likelihood that they changed their
mind and so as soon as you get the yes
it means that you've said everything is
sufficient and everything after that
point increases the risk that they
reverse their answer you got what you
needed get to the [__] truck get your
[__] move back there and then get it
done now let's go through the scenario
of I do have somebody already and I was
curious if you have somebody who taks
out your trash I do yeah yeah same
question she's asking if they have the
provider or not now he says yes here do
they also do it for free for this month
so I now have to have an alternative
scenario that I can plant like an
alternative offer also as an aside in a
life scenario you want to sound like
someone they know and people they know
don't say hi the reason that I'm calling
is if you were on a call script you'd
say hey is this
Jason pause and they'll be like yeah be
like hey this is Alex pause and then and
then they're like where the [__] do I
know Alex from now here I ask I'm like
hey how's it going I'm not saying hey my
name's Alex and I'm here to take your
trash out and I want to like breathe are
they as awesome and smiley as me I'm a
big Rapport guy I like cracking jokes at
all times in sales now that takes a
little bit more skill but it disarms
people and people are way less likely to
be rude to somebody who's just being
incredibly positive upbeat and sunny and
so you can be as ridiculous saying well
do they give you free Smiles it's such a
pattern up that people are like what the
what is this guy saying they're not
going to be like [__] you they're going
to be like you know what I no they don't
give me free Smiles they be like well
they should be cuz with a house like
this I mean how much trash you must be
creating a ton of trash and that makes
my job better I love trash right like I
could say that kind of stuff and they're
like God this guy's insane but like at
least he's funny and so I could
literally have the exact same service
and just CU they like me better they'll
give me the business but I pair that
with what I say here is are they giving
it to you for free no no no they're not
guess what that makes me better than the
guy that they have right now and so then
it's like cool he did me a favor on this
he's like so it's just free forever and
it's like no it's not free forever but I
can Cod to my truck come back and be
like yep just to be clear like it's
going to be free for this month so the
next three pickups or four pickups are
on the house and that's just a way to
earn your trust earn your business and
hopefully give you some free Smiles on
the house and then after that it just
goes at 29 bucks a month great you have
your IDE on you cuz I'd ask for that
he'd go get his wallet he'd come back
with his ID so they come with their ID
you write down the information say cool
can I trade you for the card you want to
use you hold on to it until they give
you the card then you swap cards you
write down the credit card information
so that they don't mess up the number
because if they write it down they might
change a number so it doesn't go through
so you write the card information say
awesome let me get your autograph
boom number three the one that
everyone's afraid of I take out the
Johnson's trash and they wanted me to
take out your trash I will tell you this
if you ever do door to door which is the
most aggressive of the sales like the
hardest one to do in my opinion you will
earn respect forever from everyone
everyone knows what it takes to be a
door to door salesman it's like you have
to have thick skin and you got to learn
how to talk to people if you look at
Jeff basos you look at Bill Gates you
look at Mark Cuban you look at Warren
Buffett you look at some of the most
successful people in the world they
started in a door to-door face tof face
toe-to-toe selling environment where
they got to get rejected you have to
learn how to sell as a base skill and it
doesn't mean that you have to make money
from selling but you have to learn the
skill because you're going to have to
sell your wife you're going to have to
sell your kids you're going to have to
sell your employees you're going to have
to sell your investors you're going to
have to sell customers and so learning
how to get rejected and moving on with
your life and realizing that nose are
just coins that you toss in the machine
where you roll before you get your win
you can just remember that that you're
putting it together Brick by Brick the
success that you want built on nose then
you get to where you want to go faster
and just don't take it seriously that
guy's having a bad day has nothing to do
with me I'm just asking if he wants to
take his trash out hey in case this
disclaimer wasn't obvious this is a
studio setting and we did it this way so
that we could have perfect illustrations
of each scenario real life is hardly
that clean some people answer the door
with a gun but this just gives you an
idea of just how to literally take the
first step knock on the door talk to the
stranger ask the girl out do the thing
and not be afraid of getting no because
no is the price of yes so cold Outreach
presents three problems that we will
need to solve together problem number
one is that you don't have their contact
information number two is that even if I
did contact them what do I say which
comes down to a script and an offer and
the third thing I've got the contacts I
know what to say what my offer is but
I'm not getting enough replies number
one if we're trying to solve how do you
contact someone you have to build a list
so you build a list in three ways number
one is that you build it with software
just Google software for list insert
whatever your avatar name is for
plumbers for home services for whatever
you pay a monthly fee you export a list
that meets your criteria the second way
you do it is you go to Brokers Brokers
are people who own lists and they sell
those lists to multiple people and so
you go to Mr list broker you say hey
this is a list that I'm looking for how
many you got and they'll say I've got
177,000 contacts that means these
criteria you say awesome how much and
then you do a little negoti negoti and
then option number three is you use the
old elbow grease method which is that
you assemble the list yourself now
assembling the list yourself is in my
opinion the most valuable way to do it
because it's going to be a virgin list
in the first two scenarios other
businesses are also going to that
software also going to those Brokers and
so those leads might be tired of getting
hit up it still works the long-term in
my opinion best way to do this is to
find the leads yourself and you do that
through looking at Yelp Google Maps
databases that exist online for free and
you basically scrape them yourself you
can also go to Facebook groups Reddit
forums things like that where people are
already assembled together all of these
things are ways that you can build lists
and the list should just have the way
that you can contact them the second is
you're like what do I say well I have
the script inside of $100 million leads
you can do that now the second part is
bfv you're like what's bfv bfv is big
fast value you'll notice that what I
said with him was I had a free offer
ready in my back pocket so I could
disarm him if you're talking to
strangers they're not going to be as
friendly as the people who know you
they're not going to be as polite and so
you have to be even better with them
with an amazing offer I'm saying
something that is superior to what other
people are charging for you'll be able
to win more business and it's actually
one of the biggest Force multipliers
especially on cold Outreach to get
people to say yes because they don't
trust you so you have to give them a big
incentive to do it anyways the third is
I'm not getting enough replies and you
solve that with one thing volume volume
of reach out being willing to accept NOS
100 no a th NOS to get to your yes and
we do that through Automation and
through collaboration so you get other
people to do more volume with you and
you also do technology to automate
different portions of reach outs because
believe it or not every part of this
process of building the list uh getting
your you know phone system set up if
you're doing cold calling if you're
setting up accounts to do cold DMS all
of these things are automatable to a
great degree and so get good at Tech
because it will give you huge leverage
on the amount of replies that you will
get back for the effort you put in and
so method number four is one of the
biggest baddest methods because it is
the fastest and also the most risky to
do but if you know how to do it well you
can get bags
of this this is money a bag of money so
we just knocked on doors of complete
strangers to get our first customers
doing cold Outreach and now we'll
transition to our fourth and final of
the core 4 running paid ads are you
backed up in
trash
you smell that smell is that what your
Sunday night smells like when your trash
is built up from the whole week does the
smell of your trash drive you bananas
because that time is over now what's
that you missed your child's practice
again you didn't get to watch your
favorite show again you only have so
many minutes in the day why would you
spend it taking out your trash Alex did
you take the trash out I'm watching the
game on my
phone ever feel like like that you don't
have to anymore what's that you love
trash as much as I do no impossible no
one loves trash more than me and so why
would you rob me of the opportunity to
clean your trash up for you is this you
every trash
day a I missed it no if this is what
your Monday looks like or whatever your
trash day is the day after you miss it
then you know exactly what I'm talking
about and so having seen house after
house after house busy professionals
working home forgetting to take their
trash out running after the truck to try
and get it only to realize that they
have to smell their trash for another
week or until the next pickup day it's
terrible and so I decided to make a
business just to solve that problem and
so we do three things better than
everybody else number one is that we
will never miss a pickup day ever we
guarantee that because if we ever do we
will give you three free months if we
miss even one pickup day because we're
so reliable at it number two is that we
will always be on on time and so you're
not like when are they going to pick it
up I know it's out there so your trash
isn't just sitting on front of your door
for a day while you wait for us to pick
it up we say that we're going to be
there at 7:00 we're going to be there at
7:00 and the third thing is is that you
will only hear two statements from our
team yes sir no sir yes ma'am no ma'am
that's it it's surfaced with a smile if
that sounds interesting click the link
or call 1800 Alex trash dum dum dum dum
dum dum we are here running paid ads
today the fourth of the core 4 talking
to people who don't know you one to many
this is how running paid ADS works
there's lots of free value in someone's
Newsfeed whether it's their television
that they're watching or they're looking
at the Instagram or the Tik Tok and then
there's a PID ad that goes in between
the value that they're receiving and
then these are the strangers which you
pay the platform to gain access to now
when we run a paid ad there's really
three parts to it you've got the hook
you've got the meat of the video which
is just like retain by the way if you're
like hook retain reward it's like very
similar the only difference is at the
very end we're just going to make a call
to action right whereas in a piece of
content you might not do that and just
have some sort of funny moment or
something that makes it more sharable
that's the main difference between the
two and so the way that I've made ads
cuz I've made ads for a long time the
bulk of my material net worth has been
made running paid advertising so I have
a decent amount of experience doing it
so let's watch together are you backed
up in trash right off the bat we do have
the hook which is a question it's a yes
based question are you backed up now I
have three visual cues here to create
curiosity and create a call out and
filtering mechanism man with glove trash
slightly in the background so this just
looks weird and so I'm going to get
someone to maybe give me a half a second
of their attention if this is what your
Monday looks like so what I just did was
present the problem you'll notice that
all three of these things is simply
honing in on who I want to respond
because when you're with ads the reach
is guaranteed you're spending money to
reach eyeballs you want to make sure the
ad communicates that this is for this
specific type of person so they respond
you'll notice there's different ways
that you can start an ad with a call out
all right so the call out usually goes
before the hook the call out is you're
trying to say to this specific Avatar
this is for you you can do visual call
call outs or you can do auditory call
outs visual call out is something can
see with their eyes that says this is
for me an auditory call out is me saying
Las Vegas homeowners this is who I'm
talking to which is the best hook is
saying this is for you and then you put
your real hook which is the question or
the lead to the ad forgetting to take
their trash out running after the truck
to try and get it these are all just
paint points people who are busy at work
they don't have time they're coming back
home they're forgetting their trash day
only to realize that they have to smell
their trash for another week or until
the next pickup day pain they have to
smell their trash because they forgot
about it and it's sitting there the
whole point here is we're agitating the
pain we're bringing up like oh yeah this
is important I really do need to fix
this this is something that I hate
having to deal with and so we do three
things better than everybody else so
notice I'm then introducing three things
all right so when I was selling fitness
programs I sold Fitness Nutrition
accountability trying to come up with
three things for whatever the core
service helps people know that you're
about to tell them what it is so that
opens the loop so they're more likely to
listen and then it just gives them a way
to organize the information so they can
know the benefits and I've just found
three works great number one is that
that we will never miss a pickup day
ever and so I present the probably the
biggest pain point that they have
because that's what I intro the clip
with I put my guarantee right in the
middle sometimes you can put the
guarantee at the end sometimes you put
the guarantee at the beginning so you
can move the guarantee around it felt
like it matched most with this pain
point and saying not only that just to
go above and beyond I'm going to deliver
this really fast value crazy amazing
offer so if we miss one day we're going
to give you 3 months free now all you
got to do is make sure that you don't do
that and if you have a business then why
would you miss it but it sounds insane
number two is that we will always be on
time all right the other issue is like
what other pain points are there it's
like well even if you know that what day
that someone's coming there do you want
to have trash poed up in front of your
house it's another pain point so the
deeper you know your avatar and the
deeper you know the pain points that
they're experiencing around whatever the
problem is the more detailed you can be
in description of the pain and so copy
and advertising is about the details the
smell of the trash the chasing after it
the having it pile up in front of your
house the smell when Neighbors come in
not just like you smelling it but like
have you ever had somebody else come in
cuz that affects status so there's
different ways that you can attack the
same same problem the first one I say
might not be the one that they feel like
they suffer from so I want to say
multiple things so that one of them hits
a pain point and they're like wow this
does affect me and the third thing is is
that you will only hear two statements
from our team yes sir yes ma'am what's
the next paino is they probably have a
lot of low-skilled laborers who pick up
trash who are not that friendly and
don't have a lot of Rapport and so for
me to just Elevate our service to
everybody else to say yes sir no sir yes
ma'am no ma'am because in today's day
and age no one treats anyone with
respect and so my company would be about
that because respect would be a paino
for these types of individuals and now
we transition to CTA which is the call
to action so that we actually get them
to do something from this app if that
sounds interesting click the link or
call 1800 Alex trash and that is one
example of the app you can have one or
two or three kind of meaty portions of
it where you hit on the pain a couple
different ways maybe talk about the
benefits in a couple different ways but
you can have way more hooks because the
hook is going to be the most important
part of this ad because 80% of people
are going to decide not to watch your ad
in the first 3 seconds so that's the
part you test the most if you can get
them to buy the ad in the first 3
seconds you have bought yourself more
time to consume the rest of it is this
you every trash day so it's a yes based
question in front of two visual call
outs that look like somebody you is a
homeowner who is trash that would be the
hook you smell that smell is that what
your Sunday night smells like yes based
question with a very weird intro that
might catch people's attention
does the smell of your trash drive you
bananas so that is a yes based question
with humor and like if I wanted to
attract doctors I wouldn't dress this
way and I wouldn't be in the setting so
the setting and the Avatar of the person
in the ad will do more to attract the
right types of people than anything else
if you want to track more women put
women in the ads and if you're like man
I'm a guy and surprisingly all of my
clients are men it's probably because
you're in the ads so if you want to have
twice the reach have two or three or
four different people in the ads that
you have it's one of the easiest ways to
double or triple your business or lead
flow what's that you missed your child's
practice again didn't get to watch your
favorite show again all right so here's
two yes based questions that those are
both pain yes based questions if they
say yes I have been missing these things
then I connect that to trash I'm
bridging it to the trash problem it's
really a problem of not having time I'm
just choosing to put that towards trash
what's that you love trash as much as I
do so just like that we've got a hook
and a lot of there's visual action at
the beginning of this to break the
attention of the normal news feed that
someone might be experiencing or the TV
that they're watching Alex did you take
the trash out I'm watching the game on
my phone so that is a relatable moment
that every man has had when they get
asked to take out the trashes you're
just doing something else that you'd
rather do besides take the trash out and
so each of these hooks can lead right
into that original first video I sent
you just cut off the first 5 seconds and
then you use this and then it Clips
right to there's three things that we do
better than everybody else and then we
go right into it and that's how you make
pay adts and that gives us the fourth
way that you can get customers in the
core for for trash business or any other
business you want to start and when we
put them all together it looks like
this boms
[Applause]
[Music]
away so it'll be a montage of you
throwing trash bags over your shoulder
dumping it into the big recepticle
you're going to be spraying the money
gun everywhere cuz you've turned so much
trash Into Cash we'll edit this down for
YouTube we'll make it for the podcast
we'll post on Tik Tok shorts everything
what do you
think I think that idea is
garbage